there is some good news I don't want to
leave you on all this Downer kind of
moons there's some really good news
Sharon Osbourne
has a
decided that BLM is in fact a scam
as Kanye West declared the other day BLM
is a scam and she wants her money back
do you agree with Kanye's Point
um I don't know what his point is
actually I don't know I think that's why
I say I can't answer it I don't know
what his point is I mean he said that
black lives matter is a scam
oh well we gave nine hundred thousand
dollars to that and
um I'd like my money Bank yeah yeah well
she could have said that before
wow an amazing statement there
there's so much there's so much in that
statement because what Sharon Osborne is
saying is you couldn't really admit this
before but I want my money back so she's
actually saying that Kanye and Candace
did kill black lives matter as they said
that they did and Candace has a new
movie on this coming out that is I think
gonna put the final nail in that coffin
it's coming out uh just this week I
believe it's going to be absolutely
fabulous
so she's saying yeah that's true and I
have long known that this thing was a
scam but now I'm allowed to say it and I
want my nine hundred thousand dollars
back because it was all scam and we know
that the leaders of it basically just
exploited George Floyd who no one
actually really cared about none of the
people who pretended to care about him
actually really cared about him they
just used him as a symbol to raise a lot
of money and buy big mansions in
California and yeah I want my money back
that's what she's saying and and this
could be effective
Sharon Osborne is never going to get a
penny back but if you have all of a
sudden
prominent people coming in saying give
me my money back this is a scam I'm
going to throw my financial waiter in
she I suspect felt like she was being
extorted into giving money
I remember when BLM took over Southern
California you had businesses posting
receipts in their windows
of donations to the BLM organization
like like blood over their door frames
to say please please agents of death
pass by this house don't kill us you
have people saying this is a black owned
business in other words go kill whitey
don't don't go after Russell I don't and
the white people I donated money please
again it's no different than the mob
except that the mob used to only take 10
of your stuff and the libs come in and
they basically want everything
that's the difference
that's that's the big difference here
and now Sharon Osbourne is admitting
that I think a lot of people feel that
way and if more people just get a little
bit of courage to say yeah no actually
the established narrative about BLM was
complete BS and we shouldn't have gone
along with it and I'm sorry we allowed
ourselves to be extorted that's that's
uh fine that's fine you know where you
really see this is a completely
different point
but I have to get to it today
horrible terribly sad story two children
were killed and a mother was critically
injured after the family's dogs attacked
now before I tell you what kind of dog
it was
you already know right was it a DOT was
it was it a wiener dog
was it a pug
was it a golden retriever
no
you know it was a pit bull because it's
always a pit bull because the majority
of the time when a dog mauls somebody or
eats a poor little kid it's a pit bull
we know this because the pit bulls were
bred to do this that's what they're for
and yet
we are told by the experts of our
society no no that's not true it's no
there's no such thing as a bad breed of
dog well maybe not good or bad but it's
just the breed was bred to to be
extremely violent and and so now we have
them and we have them around
two-year-old little kids that's why
these stories keep happening no no not
my dog there's no such thing as a bad
dog breed just bad owners no they just
didn't love their dog the right way oh
that's weird a lot of people just not
loving their pitbulls the right way and
for some reason the people the bad dog
owners they always seem to own pit bulls
and it's just coincidentally always the
pit bulls that are attacking people
and just coincidentally they're
genetically built for that
but that's just a weird coincidence
it's weird these pit bulls always at the
center of such coincidences
I know this is going to be controversial
I know some people like the dogs
we should obviously kill all the pit
bulls right it's not enough even to
sterilize them because the problem is
not that there will be more pit bulls in
the future the problem is the pit bulls
are the dogs that attack everybody now
and threaten People's Kids now and lead
to these horrible stories and the
parents say oh no the dogs were the dog
was never violent before the dog lived
with us for years yeah and the dog was
never violent until he was and whenever
the dogs are violent it just usually
most of the time tends to be the pit
bulls and we have no reason to tolerate
that we as a society have a great reason
to protect against that
there is no there was no Second
Amendment right to a pit bull there is
no natural law reason to have a pit bull
we we have to admit reality
okay this is not and we have to admit
that all the all the experts in this
case on the dogs are no no it's actually
just training and actually actually if
you look at this statistic and actually
if you no it's just not true we know we
know it we all know it okay even the
Pitbull owners know it okay stopped in
the ah stop denying things that you know
are true because some lib Egghead with
uh some kind of mellifluous argument
has convinced you not to trust your gut
in your head and history and everything
that we know is true okay stop trying to
make yourselves so gullible
this is true forget the pit bulls for a
second this is true on transgenderism
it's drawn abortion it's true on our
country's history it's strong crime it's
running immigration it's throwing all of
these things okay we know basic stuff we
have common sense we have eyes we can
see nature we see stuff all around us
okay we have at least two brain cells to
rub together we know that
and the purpose of leftist politics the
goal of leftist politics is to tell you
to ignore everything you know
and to convince yourself of their
fantasies
to convince yourself that Richard Levine
is actually a woman
it's okay to trust your prejudices it's
okay to trust received wisdom it's okay
to trust your faculties of Reason okay
they've got a much better record you're
going to be called a conspiracy theorist
for trusting all those things but
they've got a much better record than
the so-called experts today is music
Monday okay
we've got a a song
that was requested by one of the great
members of this show who will we will
see in the member block and my producer
Ben Davies has teed it up for me he
tells me I'm going to hate the song but
we'll see the rest of the show begins
now if you don't want to miss it Well
you certainly don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us we will see
you over at the member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]